mais d'abord l'écoeurement et
l'indignation à la banque alimentaire de
blois deux camions qui servent à la
collecte quotidienne des denrées
alimentaires ont été dégradées le
week-end dernier les rendant
inutilisables 4500 bénéficiaires dans la
précarité vont devoir en payer les
conséquences
plus d'explications dans ce reportage de
florent clavel voilà ce que nous avons
découvert lundi matin en arrivant au
travail pour récupérer donc les camions
les tableaux de bord a haché
méticuleusement caroline fallourd et la
directrice de la banque alimentaire du
loir-et-cher encore abattu vingt-quatre
heures après le démontage des deux
camions de collecte de l'association
mais aussi d'un utilitaire
ils sont aujourd'hui inutilisables pas
trop de qualificatifs en fait parce que
c'est assez odieux de s'attaque à une
structure évidemment de lutte contre la
pauvreté nous paralyse actuellement en
pleine crise sanitaire voilà est
extrêmement dommageable pour nous mais
surtout pour les bénéficiaires
évidemment de l'aide alimentaire
d'ordinaire ces camions frigorifiques
ramasse les produits frais des grandes
surfaces pour les redistribuer à une
trentaine d'associations dead
alimentaire en loir et cher elle est de
4500 bénéficiaires mais cet après midi
le quai d'expédition évident
évidemment aujourd'hui l'activité
l'activité arrêté puisqu'on a relayé ces
partis d'activité à d'autres
associations qui nous sont venus en aide
pour éviter les ruptures de service
c'est le cas de la passerelle
l'association a son propre camion grâce
au renfort de ses bénévoles
elle a exceptionnellement pu assurer une
rame à ce là un arrivage de supermarché
qui va garnir les étagères de son
épicerie solidaire une solution de
dépannage
ça fait bien sûr travail en plus un
bénévole mieux tout ça d'ailleurs avec
jean pierre est un salarié mais sinon
cdb
qui aujourd'hui à d'autres affaires et
puis sûrement sont venus en sans se
poser de questions en attendant une
éventuelle aide d assurance pour
bénéficier de camions de remplacement la
banque alimentaire du loir et cher lance
un appel à la générosité
elle espère le prêt d'un véhicule
frigorifique pour continuer à venir en
aide aux plus démunis